اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره للاشتباكات في السودان ظاهريا هو
يوم عيد لكن فعليا الحزن هو الذي يخيم على
الوضع لا يزال اطلاق النار مستمرا في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش بالخرطوم الوضع بات
مخيفا فيما جدد المبعوث الامامي الدعوه
لوقف اطلاق النار خلال ايام العيد لفتح
ممرات امنه وهو ما لم يحدث
[موسيقى]
اعراب الدمار واصوات الرصاص ما تركت مجالا
لفرحين يستحقه اهلنا في كل بلادنا الحبيبه
فاننا لجد حزينين لهذا المال لكن يبقى
الامل الدائم في اننا مع شعبنا العظيم
سنتجاوز هذه المحنه ونخرج منها اكثر وحده
وقوه وتماسك ويزداد هتافنا قوه جيش واحد
شعب واحد فاننا على ثقه في تجاوز هذه
المحنه بالدربه والحكمه والقوه بما يحافظ
على امن ووحده البلاد وفيما يمكننا من
الانتقال الامن للحكم المدني المواطنين
الشرفاء انما اذ نترحم على كل الشهداء
بلادي نتمنى الشفاء للجرحى وندعو الله ان
يعود علينا هذا العيد وبلادنا تنعم بالامن
والسلام تحيه لكم جند بلادي وانتم تقدمون
انفسكم لهذا الوطن العزيز عاش السودان حره
مستقلا
شوارع الخرطوم شهدت انتشار دوريات للجيش
السوداني بعد ان انسحبت قوات الدعم السريع
من مواقع في العاصمه معناتها
من تصوير قاعده الدعم السريع في منطقه جبل
سركاب شمال ام درمان وكانت قوات الجيش
السوداني سيطرت على القاعده قبل عده ايام
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا حسب الانباء الوارده
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد مقتل امريكيا
واحدا على الاقل خلال هذه الاشتباكات التي
بدات قبل سته ايام في السودان اذا لاول
مره تعلن اخر رجال الامريكيه مقتل احد
رعاياها خلال هذه الاشتباكات لم تتبين الى
الان هويه هذا الامريكي او الجهه التي
يتبع لها سواء كان مواطنا ام دبلوماسيا
لكن الخارجيه الان تؤكد مقتل امريكي واحد
على الاقل خلال الاشتباكات بالطبع
سنوافيكم بمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه
المعلومه حاله ورودها لكن المؤكد الان بان
امريكيه سقط وهو ربما الاجنبي الاول الذي
يسقط خلال هذه المواجهات التي بدات قبل
سته ايام في السودان على كل حال الكاميرا
العربيه وثقت من داخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه تفاصيل اول ايام عيد الفطر
المبارك بعد اشتباكات ومعارك شهدها مطار
مروي وال الجويه الملحقه بالمطر
نحن الان داخل الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاه في
مدينه ملوي بالولاية الشماليه هذه ملامح
العيد في اول يوم من ايام عيد الفطر
المبارك
الله اكبر الله
ومن ارض مروه طيبه الصامته الطاهره
لنرسل رساله
للشعب السوداني بنقول لهم ان احنا صامدين
والعدوى العدو انكسر ومروي امن ان شاء
الله
واكد تماما بان الولايه خاليه تماما من اي
وجود للفلول عدد من الاسر في الولايات
الشماليه وتحديدا في مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه فقدت ابنائها خلال الاشتباكات
العنيفه المسلحه التي دارت خلال العمليات
العسكريه داخل المطار وداخل القاعده
العسكريه سنقترب اكثر لنتعرف على شكل
العيد في الاسر التي فقدت بعضا من ابنائها
خلال هذه الحرب
ولدي
الشهيد احمد محمد احمد عوض الله
الذي استشهد بمطار مرغ بالقاعده الجويه
هو عند الله شهيدا ان شاء الله
والحمد لله رب العالمين
في في الاحداث اللي
وعندنا والله
يعني لطالما ترسخت الطمانينه والامن في
هذه المنطقه كرسوق اشجار النخيل في ارض
الشمال ياتي العيد ودعوات الناس هنا ان
يعم الامن والاستقرار والسلام ارجى
السودان نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه
والحدث محليه مروي الولايه الشماليه
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اخر التطورات على الارض سالم
اهلا وسهلا اخر التطورات ان هناك يعني شبه
هدنه لانها متقاطعه وهناك تسمع اصوات
للمدافع وكذلك
التي كان فيها
النزاعات
لكن
المصادر ان هناك قوات من الجيش السوري
متحركه من جهه ام درمان مجموعه من العربات
ستصل
هي متجهه في العاده الى المنطقه التي
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع وهذا الدعم
السريع
في المظلات وامتداد الشعبيه كذلك
في المظلات والشعبيه
والى هذه المناطق هذه
الى هذه المناطق طب ماذا يعني ذلك اذا كنا
نتحدث عن هدنه بدايه فهل هي هدنه غير
معلنه لانه الدعم السريع عرض هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام خلال ايام العيد والجيش رفض
هذا الامر والان انت تتحدث عن شبه هدنه هل
يمكن القول بان قوات الجيش
تستغل هذا الهدوء للتحرك الوصول الى معاقل
قوات الدعم السريع في ام درمان
النقطه المهمه ان الجيش السوداني لم يعلن
عنه حتى الان في هذه اللحظات
وهذا مما يعني انه يعني ما دام انه لم
يعلن الهدنه فتصبح الهدنه مرطغيه بهذا
بهذا النص يعني لان الغنه من طرف واحد
يعني ان هناك
لم يلتزم يعني فقط فقط اود ان افهم منك
هذه النقطه سالم هل
يصح القول بان قوات الدعم السريع الان
تلتزم بالهدنه بينما الجيش لم يوافق عليها
ولم يلتزم بها وبالتالي ليس هناك اطلاق
نار وردود اطلاق نار هل هذا هو الوضع الان
لا ليس هذا بهذه الدقه لانه ايضا قوات
الدعم السريع في هذا اليوم لكن لا ندري هل
هو رد
لاشتباك هو اصلا صدر عنها لانه كنا نسمع
دوري الرصاص نسمع كذلك اصوات المدافع
ومبادره الطائرات والتي تستخدمها هو الدعم
السريع بالتاكيد
ابرز الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم
العاصمه الخرطوم في المناطق التي هي اصلا
فيها الاشتباك منذ
بدا هذه الازمه في منطقه محيط القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني
نقول انه كثيف في هذه المناطق هي مناطق
محدوده ليست مناطق كبيره جدا لكنها محدوده
في هذه المناطق تنتشر قوات الدعم السريع
وتنفذ الشيطان عن الشوارع في هذه الشوارع
يظهر ان الجيش السوداني ربما يحصر نار
النزاع
المناطق على حركه قوات الدعم السريع في
هذه المنطقه بالذات منطقه البحري خاصه وان
هذه الحركه في الشوارع في منطقه بحريه
تثيره للمواطنين وايضا هناك شكوى من عديد
من المواطنين وصلت الينا فيما يتعلق ببعض
المضايقات كذلك عدم القدره على الحركه في
هذه الشرائع مضايقات تتعلق بعمليه النهب
وسلب اما
تحديد حركه الناس
هم يعني المواطنون بمختلف الاشكال ربما هي
بعد نقول انها هي المضايقات بعد ذلك تختلف
القصص والروايه من شخص لاخر لكنها في
كل حال سؤال فيما يتعلق بموضوع السيطره
على
ربما القياده قياده الجيش في الخرطوم هناك
فيديوهات تم بثها لقوات الجيش داخل مقر
القياده هل يمكن القول بانه تم السيطره
على مقر القياده بشكل كامل من قبل قوات
الجيش وان ما يحدث من مناوشات واشتباكاتها
خارج مقر القياده
نعم هذا
مصادر وكذلك اكدهم الجيش السوداني اكثر من
مره في هذه النقطه لانه هو يصير القياده
العامه وان الاشتباكات خارجه في هذا في
اصرار من قوات السريع لدخول للقياده
العامه
بالنسبه والدعم السريع هذا يفهم منه ان
الجيش تصيبه على محيط القياده العامه يعني
يضيف ايضا
التحركات تحركات الجيش السوداني
يعني يفهم منها ان الجيش السوداني الماضي
الخطه التي وضعها لهذا الامر وانه
سيحسم هذا الامر ومن ثم ينظر في تفاصيل
حالات هذا الامر بنفس
الذي قيل في بيان الجيش السوداني واكده في
مقابل هذا البيان ايضا الان سنعرض فيديو
لقوات الدعم السريع قالت بانه هذه صور لها
خلال انتشارها في شوارع وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور
في اي مكان الان حاليا ايضا
في كل السوق العربي وحوالي الان مسيطرين
هنا
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور نشرتها قوات الدعم
السريع لانتشار الدورياتها في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم يبدو ان الشوارع فارغه وهذا
يجعلني اسالك سالم بانه كيف مر يوم العيد
على السودانيين هل هناك اي مظاهر للعيد
خصوصا في العاصمه الخرطوم تابعنا هذا
الفيديو معك ويبدو ان الشوارع خاليه تماما
من الماره
نعم ايضا هنا يجب ان اؤكد امرا مهما في
موضوعنا الشوارع خاليه من الماره القلوب
من الماره تماما يفهم منه ان هذه المنطقه
تتواجد بهارات الدعم السريع وهذا من خلال
الجمله التي قمت بها المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها اقوال الدعم السريعه
على العكس تماما
[موسيقى]
لدينا مشكله في في سماع صوتك لا يصلني
بشكل واضح على كل حال تفضل البقاء معي
ساعود لك لكن دعني اربط الاتصال مع اللواء
الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز دراسات الدوليه
دكتور امين تعليقك على ما يحدث الان في
العاصمه الخرطوم هناك حاله
عدم يقين تجاه ما يحدث يعني البعض يعتقد
بان هناك هدنه غير معلنه والبعض الاخر
يقول لا هناك اشتباكات متقطعه هل هناك
رغبه
بهدنه لكن لا احد يود التنازل ما حقيقه ما
يحدث من وجهه نظر عسكريه الان في العاصمه
الخرطوم
مساء الخير مرحبا بك ومرحبا كل عام وانت
بالف خير
اليوم السابع
اول ايام العيد
وبالتالي اي اختراق او لهذه الغنه بوابه
المسلحه
الواقع في الارض الان هو تدعم السريع بدات
الخروج من وسط العاصمه خرجت من نطار
القياده العامه مطار الخرطوم غسل الريال
واصبحت منتشره في الشوارع الفرعيه القوميه
بالتفتيش
ونهبهم وانا في تعليق يقول انه القوات
المسلحه تاثير
السودان
عموما
الحرب الان تحولت الى المرحله هي مرحله
المطارده والتنشيط للشوارع القوات المساله
تطالبكم من شارع
طيب عندي سؤال
لواء امين انه نقول بان قوات الدعم السريع
الان باتت في اطراف العاصمه الخرطوم لكن
كيف نفسر الاشتباكات التي تدور حول مقر
القياده العامه واصوات القصف المدفعي
ربما الرصاص
ماذا يحدث من يقصف من
ليس قصدي هو والغصب عنده ذخيره معينه
وعيارات معينه عندما تاتي الطائرات التي
تستطلع المناطق وهم
يستحقون المضادات وبعدها طيران اللي هي
الاسلحه الرباعيه الصالحه عاليه جدا
بالمناسبه
نستمع الى هذا القصف لا ادري اذا كنت تسمع
ما يحدث انفجارات
اذن كما قلنا هناك انفجارات بمحيط القياده
العامه
واستخدام للرشاشات الخفيفه والمتوسطه
الثقيله يعني هذا ما اقوله بانه لازال
هناك تواجد لقوات الدعم السريع في هذه
المنطقه الحيويه هل يتركزون في مناطق
معينه حول قصر الضيافه التلفزيون
مقر القياده
لتحقيق اي انتصار ولو معنوي هناك كيف تنظر
الى هذا الامر
اما اصوات السيارات المتعدده
الفضائيه عموما
[موسيقى]
الغطاء الرياضي
العامه
هذه المناطق الذي كان حول الزراعه هم
يتحركون متحركه
في هذه المناطق هذه المرحله هي مرحله
المطالبه
المواضيع المدنيه
مع قوات المش
م طيب
لواء لواء امين فقط يعني قبل قليل عرضنا
فيديو لقوات الدعم السريع قالت فيه بانها
تنتشر في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ذلك
بقليل نشر الجيش ايضا لقطات من نفس
المنطقه وسط الخرطوم ونفى وجود قوات الدعم
السريع نتابع الفيديو ثم نعود باستكمال
الصور معا
[موسيقى]
الساحه الخضراء ما في اي حاجه كله ينتهى
والله
مبروك والله
اطمن الناس ما في اي حاجه الناس
يلا مع السلامه
يعني فكره فكره ان يخرج احد ويقول نطمئن
الناس لا يوجد اي شيء في الخرطوم ربما
هناك مبالغه بالامر موضوع السيطره هو ربما
مدار جدل خصوصا في ظل استمرار هذه
الاشتباكات التي نستمع اليها على الهواء
مباشره
لواء امين تعليقك على هذه الحرب الاعلاميه
الدائره الى جانب الحرب والاشتباكات
العسكريه في السودان
ذكي
يستطيع ان يصوره ويرسلوا عبر الواتساب الى
اي من القنوات
تعليقك الذكي بانه نفس المنطقه دعم شويه
طويله الجيش انا دليل
ويتحرك يكون الان
فيديو انه موجود العظيم هذه حرب اعلاميه
كما تفضلت وهي حرب نفسيه فيها محاوله
المغربيه لكن على الارض حتى
الجنود الموجودين والضباط
والجان فما بيتاخروا
انا اشكك في هذه ولكن
هل تشكك في ما نسمعه دعنا نسمع اصوات
الانفجارات والقصف المتبادل يعني يمكن
التشكيك بهذا الامر لكن هناك مواجهات
حقيقيه داخل العاصمه السودانيه وبالتالي
من نصدق ما نسمعه ونراه بام اعيننا ام ما
تنتج هذه الحرب الاعلاميه بين الطرفين
خصوصا ان المكونين العسكريين لا تنقصهما
للخبره ولا العتاد ولا التعداد
انا العاطي
جوجل غير متوفره الانظمه حوالي مربع
الان نحن نعلم المنطقه الشرق النيل منطقه
كابوري ضاحيه كابوريا
هذه مناطق الخصوم بحريه الاشكاليه هي هي
حرب اعلاميه
محاوله لربع المعنويات ايضا انا موجود
لانه
تعمل
سريعات من مخابيعها
ايضا موجوده في منطقه
مباشره القوه العامه
لذلك لا يمكن مقارنتها بمجموعات
هي كانت جزء من القوات المسلحه وتمرد
جيد الان سته ايام اللواء امين من
الاشتباكات لم تحسم المعارك بشكل يعني
كامل لصالح احد ما السيناريوهات المتوقعه
بالنسبه لكم عسكريا خلال الساعات والايام
القادمه
الاسلحه المتطوره ومن الطائرات ومن
المدفعيه الصاروخيه خوفا على المدنيين
حمايه المدنيين الخطط تمر بتركيز وبدقه
المنشات الحيويه حتى لا نخسر البيئه
المدنيه لذلك هذا هو السبب الذي ادى الى
اطار الى اليوم السابع
المتوقع انه هذه القوات بدات تظن من
التشديد انقطع خطوره الامداد انقطع
الاتصال مع غيار هذا
اصبحت الان تعمل برد الفعل الخاص
يكون في في مكان واحد بيتصرفوا من واقع
المغرب امامه وهذا الامر مع التطهير يتم
اخراجه
لكن رغم كل ما تفضلت به ورغم كل الاجراءات
الاجراءات والاحتياطات التي يتخذها الجيش
السوداني حسب منسق البرامج الطبيه في
السودان يعني يدخل 400 شخص يوميا الى
المستشفيات
بمعدل يفوق 40 مره ما كان عليه قبل هذه
الاشتباكات
يؤكد بانه عشرات الوفيات تصل للمستشفيات
او وهناك المئات ممن يتلقون العلاج نتيجه
تلقي الاصابه بالرصاص في الراس او في
الجذع او في الصدر او الحوض وان هناك اكثر
من 600 شخص
وبالتالي رغم كل هذه الاحتياطات
المدنيون يدفعون الثمن الاكبر
هذه واحده حرب المدن وحرب الشوارع انه
بيكون فيها من المدنيين لكن هذه الارقام
فيها وزير الصحه كان يتحدث قبل
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه تتحدث عن كرتونيه
شخص قتلوا الان 600
لكل جهه
فقط دعنا نستمع الى صوت الاشتباكات لا
استطيع سماعك من صوت الاشتباكات نعود لك
لو
اء
الانفجارات واطلاق النار
والقذائف ما زال مستمرا مشاهدينا حول محيط
القياده العامه في الخرطوم هذه صور مباشره
وخاصه بقناه العربيه نبثها لكم في اول
ايام العيد
فقد بدات هذه الاشتباكات تشتد فور انتهاء
الهدنه التي استمرت لاربع وعشرين ساعه
والتي تخللتها انتهاكات كثيره تبادل
الطرفان الجيش والدعم السريع الاتهامات
حول من يخرقها
الدعم السريع عرض هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
رفضها الجيش واشترط خروج الدعم السريع من
العاصمه
للالتزام بهذه الهدنه وبين
الفين والاخرى
تشتد وتيره هذه الاشتباكات والقصف
لواء امين يعني ما يحدث له تداعيات على
اكثر من مستوى الان تم تسجيل مقتل امريكي
وايضا اربعه من الموظفين الامميين وهناك
انباء عن دراسه البعثات الدبلوماسيه لبدء
اجلاء بعثاتها من العاصمه الخرطوم برايكم
قرار من هذا النوع الا يشير الى ان الامور
تتجه الى الاسوا وانه ربما لا فرصه للعوده
الى طاوله الحوار
لواء امين تسمعني
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع اللواء
امين اسماعيل على كل حال نعود الى سالم
الهاشمي سالم استمعت معنا وتابعت ذوي
الانفجارات واطلاق النار الكثيف في محيط
القياده العامه ماذا يحدث حول القياده
العامه
فقدنا الاتصال ايضا بسالم الهاشمي
للاتصالات مع الخرطوم صعبه حقيقه في ظل
هذه الظروف ايضا الانباء تشير الى انه
هناك تقطع في خدمات الانترنت وشبكات
الاتصال في كل مره يتم فيها قصف منطقه
يتاثر احد ابراج الاتصالات تنقطع
الاتصالات وهذا وجهناه منذ بدايه تغطيتنا
التي بدات قبل سته ايام لتطورات الاحداث
في العاصمه الخرطوم هناك صعوبه حتى في
الاتصال داخل
السودان بين المدن وايضا داخل نفس المدينه
بسبب كل ما يحدث والضروات الامنيه التي
تفرض على الجيش احيانا قطع الاتصال في بعض
المناطق كون قوات الدعم السريع تستخدم هذه
الشبكات للتواصل فيما بينها وتكتيك قطع
الاتصال هو احد التكتيكات العسكريه
المستخدمه
لمواجهه هذه
على كل حال سنربط الاتصال مع ضيفنا من
الخرطوم
محمد ابو الفضل مدير تحرير جريده الاهرام
اذا كان معنا على كل حال سينضم لنا بعد
قليل
الاشتباكات على اشدها في العاصمه
السودانيه الان في اول ايام العيد وهذا
اليوم الذي كان هناك ربما بارقه امل بان
يتم تطبيق هدنه جديده بعد الهدنه التي
انقضت صباحا لكن يبدو ان الامور لا تسير
كما يشتهي سكان الخطوط
طيب ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الصحفي حافظ
كبير اهلا بك يا حافظ كل عام وانت بخير
ماذا يحدث حول مقر القياده العامه
تحيه طيبه لكم وكل عام وانتم بخير الذي
يجري حاليا هو يعني
يجري دائما او خلال الايام الماضيه هناك
اطلاق كثيف للنار وهناك دخان
يمكنه ان نلاحظه من مكان اقامته حاليا
وهناك يعني حول سيطره كل طرق على القياده
لكن الحقيقه
بشكل واضح غير واضح حتى الان هناك
عمليه اصبحت القوات المسلحه بانها عمليه
بريه فمتى المرحله الثانيه لكن حتى الان
لا لا وجود لنتائج واضحه من مصادر موثوقه
حتى الان هناك دعاء من كل طرف بانه
اصدر بيانا ونشر يعني تسجيلات مصوره بانه
كبير منها
تقول القوات المسلحه بانها ما تزال او
سيطره على القياده العامه لكن
في هذه الاشتباكات والحرب هناك ايضا حرب
اعلاميه من اجل يعني كشف نقاط رفع الروح
المعنويه لبعض لهذا الطرف او ذاك لكن لا
اعتقد حقيقه
ستقيت كثيرا لانه هناك قرائن يمكن معرفه
الحقيقه من خلالها مثل ان الخروج علنا في
القياده العامه او يعني فيديوهات ومخاطبه
تشير الى بعض الاخبار العاجله التي وردت
عن البيت الابيض في اعقاب اعلان وزاره
الخارجيه عن مقتل احد الرعايه الامريكيين
خلال هذه الاشتباكات البيت الابيض يؤكد
بانه يقوم بالتاكد من الجاهزيه لعمليه
اجلاء محتمله في السودان اذا هذه المره
الاولى التي يصرح فيها البيت الابيض بانه
هناك
جهود للتاكد من الجاهزيه اجلاء محتمله من
السودان ولكن رغم ذلك قال بانه لم يتم
اتخاذ اي قرار بشان اجلال الامريكيين من
السودان لكن
ما يحدث هو ربما استشعار لما قد تتطور
وتذهب اليه الامور في اكثر من مره اكدت
الولايات المتحده بانها لم تتخذ قرار بهذا
الشان لكن هي تتاكد الان من الجاهزيه
لاجلاء
الرعايه الامريكيين والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
من الخرطوم في ظل التطورات الاوضاع خلال
الساعات القادمه اذا كما ذكرت لنا حافظ
قبل قليل لا شيء محسوم الان في الخرطوم
وكل طرف يدعي انه سيطره على مبنى القياده
وايضا باقي المناطق الاستراتيجيه وبالتالي
كيف يمكن فهم حقيقه ما يحدث على الارض
من يمتلك الدليل على انه له اليد العليا
فيما يحدث
وبالطبع هناك يعني يعني ما تقول الامراض
بانه دليل مثل الفيديوهات التي تنشرها لكن
هناك ايضا تلاعب احيانا بالفيديوهات هناك
ايضا يعني سريعه
التبادل الاطراف الاماكن نحن في حرب سمى
بالحرب الخاص احيانا نتبادل الاطراف
الاماكن التي يسيطر عليها لكن بسرعه
بصوره يعني عامه هناك اماكن ظلت خاضعه
لسيطره احد الاطراف في فتره طويله مثل
الاذاعه والتلفزيون وقف الجمهوري
اماكن مستقره لكن بقيه الاماكن مثل
الطرقات العامه
الخرطوم غاز الارتكاز هذه متحركه حسب
مقتضيات المعرفه وحسب الاشتباكات من
القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري
والتليفزيون حسب المعلومات المتوفره الان
حسب المعلومات المتوفره لديها الذي يسيطر
على هذه الاماكن هو قوات الدعم السريع
وهناك محاولات مستمره ومكرره لاستعاده هذه
الاماكن منها وهناك يعني
الثقيله خلال ليله الماضيه وكذلك صباح
اليوم
لاستعادتها حتى الان ليس لدي معلومات
مؤكده حول نجاح القوات المسلحه في ذلك
الذي يريد ان نوكله بان هناك ايضا خارج
هذه الاماكن انتشار واسع هناك ايضا كما
اشارت العربيه في اخبارها يعني اشتباكات
جنوب الخرطوم اتجاه شارع الجزيره الى
ولايه الجزيره ايضا هناك يعني قوات قادمه
منذ الولايات التمارين التي تقع جنوب
جنوبا وكل هذه يعني اشتباك تد
ور حول الخرطوم لقطع الطريق امام اي قوات
قادمه من الولايات لدعم الاطراف وبالتالي
الذي يحدث في الخرطوم داخليا هو اشبه
بالتوازن
الى اقدام قوات من الخارج او من الخارج
الخرطوم لتراجعها كفه هذا الطرف هذا الامر
حتى الان حتى الان يعني هذا الامر غير
محسوم وحتى الان يعني لا ندري
الدخول الى الى الى الامانه التي تريد
الدخول اليها ام لا
جيد الان البيت الابيض ابلغنا الطرفين
نزاع في السودان ان الاعتداء على
الدبلوماسيين غير مقبول هذا تصريح جديد
للبيت الابيض في اعقاب اعلان الخارجيه
الامريكيه مقتل احد الرعايه الامريكيين في
السودان
واحد قتل حتى الان وقبل ذلك كان هناك
اعلان مقتل اربعه موظفين امميين في
السودان خلال اشتباكات التي دخلت يومها
السادس اليوم فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع الصحيه
هل عدد المنظومه الصحيه في العاصمه
الخرطوم
سابق عاده كان هناك عدد كبير من
المستشفيات خرجت من الخدمه هل اعيد
تفعيلها وتفعيل مراكز طبيه اخرى لاستيعاب
اعداد الجرحى نتيجه هذه الاشتباكات
بالتاكيد حتى اخر التقارير التي صورت عن
الاجابه والاطباء لم لم يعني لم لم تعود
المنظومه الطبيه حتى الان المستشفيات يعني
معطله خارجا الخدمه يعني بعض المستشفيات
اللي يعملها المرضى الاخرون وخصصت فقط
للطوارئ لعلاج الذين
المعارك ولكن بصوره عامه المنظومه كلها
حتى الان لم تعود الخدمه حسب التقارير
الاطباء وكذلك الصحه
وكذلك منظمه الصحه العالميه هناك يعني
في نظام صحي الان هو
بالمعاني من اشكالات كبيره الان
اغلى في قريبه من اماكن الاشتباكات قريبه
للقياده العامه
التي تعمل عددها قليل جدا بحسب التقارير
التي تردوا الينا من
من اطباء من قبل اللجان الاطباء ووزاره
الصحه ايضا
في الادويه والامداد الادويه خاصه ادويه
المنقذه للحياه وهذا يعني بسبب ايضا ان
الطرقات مغلقه بين بين مدن الولايه الثلاث
وكذلك ايضا بسبب عدم الامان
الصيدليات في بها مخزون وكذلك الحكومه
وبالتالي ليس هناك امداد يصل الى المستشفى
او يصل الى الصيدليات يعني
كانت المرضى بهذه الادويه الان
احتاج يعني المرضى خاصه من اصحاب الذين
يعانون من امراض مزمنه او امراض يعني
تحتاج بصوره دائما الى الى الى
تحدي اليوم اليوم
فيما يتعلق بانتشار
ربما الامراض بالسودان وتفشيها هذا ما
اكده مدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه والعون
الانساني الصادق محمد احمد للعربيه دعنا
نستمع الى تصريح ثم نعود لاستكمال الحديث
معك حافظ
اذا كما اشرنا مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للتنميه والعمل الانساني صرح بتصريحات حول
مخاوفه من انتشار وتفشي الامراض نتابع
[موسيقى]
عشان يحل مست خصوصا لان الان اصبح هناك
ازمه انسانيه كبيره وظيفه الى نقص الغذاء
ونقص المواد التموينيه وظيفه اليها اخلاء
الجرحى والجثث من الشوارع هناك كارثه
انسانيه يعني
تحيط يعني بالوضع بصوره عامه والنقشه ان
يتم ايضا انتشار الامراض من جراء وجود بعض
الجسد الكثير من الجثث الان في الشوارع
ولم يتم باخلاقها وستتحلل بمرور الايام
وقال عطيه عبد الله نقابه الاطباء في
السودان العربيه ان 11 طبيبا قتلوا خلال
المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع بالاضافه الى تعرض عدد من
المستشفيات الى القصف ما تسبب بتوقف عمل
بعضها
قاد
ر الطبيه وثلاثه من طلاب كليات الطيب
تعدت اسباب قتلهم اما بالرصاص المباشر او
سقوط دهانات داخل منازلهم نعم احد عشر في
مجموعهم 14 مستشفى تعرض للقصف المباشر او
الغير مباشر في النهايه هي تعرضت لدمار
جزء او دمار كامل ايضا هنالك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعرضت للعنف وبعضهم مصاب
للعنف الذي واجهوه في الشوارع اثناء قياما
باداء واجبهم تجاه المستشفيات القادمه
والمرضاهم
جثه في شوارع الخرطوم مئات المدنيين لقوا
حتفهم
جثه مكدسه منذ ايام لا يمكن جمعها ودفنها
على وقع الاشتباكات
القطاع الطبي كارثه انسانيه ضغط هائل على
سعته الاستيعابيه
وفق منسق البرامج الطبيه في السودان دخول
حوالي 400 شخص يوميا الى المستشفيات عشرات
الوفيات في مستشفيات الخرطوم لعدم تلقي
المصابين العلاج لا مستلزمات طبيه ولا
اكسجين
وفاه اكثر من 600 شخص والارقام مرشحه
للسياده
شادينا دعونا نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا قبل قليل لاستهداف مروحيات الجيش
السوداني لقوات الدعم السريع في الخطه
[تصفيق]
اذا مراسل العربيه اكد قبل قليل ايضا سماع
ذوي اطلاق نار ومضاده ارضيه ووسط تحليق
الطيران الحربي في ام درمان سنستفسر عن
حقيقه ما يحدث في ام درمان ايضا مع حافظ
حافظ كبير الصحفي من الخرطوم حافظ ما
المعلومات لديكم حول ما يحدث في ام درمان
محيط
التلفزيون وكذلك يعني في اطراف ام درمان
بعيدا حيث تتواجد قوات مختلفه هناك يعني
املاك طفل من خلاله القوات وكان قوات
الدعم السريع او حتى والقوات المسلحه
اشتباكات من حين لاخر لكن بصوره عامه
المتك
رر من اشتباكاته حول المبنى
في محاوله لاسترداده من قبل من قبل الجيش
مضت كل ما تنظر الايام او كل ما تنظر
ساعات تاتي اخبار بان هناك يعني جديد
الوطني استعاده هذا هذا المقر لكن يعني
ينشروا الدعم السريع فيديوهات مصوره اللي
هي
المتواجدون داخل المبنى الاذاعه لقوات
الجيش السوداني موجوده حول مبنى التلفزيون
لكن قوات الدعم السريع موجوده في داخله
كيف تفسرون ما يتم بثه من خطابات
للبرهان هل يتم بثها من خارج مبنى
التلفزيون وهل تم قطع الخدمات من قبل
الجيش عن المبنى الرئيسي للاذاعه
والتلفزيون
وبالطبع يعني كل الذي حاليا عبر التلفزيون
هو من خارج المبنى الرئيسيه معلومه للجميع
لكن الجيش
الاشاره البث واصبح مشتركه من عدد من
القنوات من قنوات
محطات ولايه والان هناك على تلفزيون
السودان لكن هذا البث ليس من الرئيسيه ليس
هناك يعني يعني وجود للجيش داخل التلفزيون
حتى يستخدم في هذا الرئيسيه وبالتالي يعني
يضيف من خارج من خارج الاستديو من خارج
مباني الاذاعه والتلفزيون
يعني ويسجل الطبع يعني من مختلف المواد
التي سجلها كما نلاحظ احيانا الهواتف
احيانا في بدايات وما الى ذلك
نخرج قليلا من العاصمه الخرطوم ونتحدث عن
ما يحدث في دارفور الانباء تشير الى ان
هناك اكثر من 100 قتيل في دارفور بسبب
الاشتباكات في ولايات
في غرب وربما شمال دارفور او شمال وجنوب
دارفور ما حقيقه ما يحدث هناك الان
في شمال يقع مبنى مبنى الطرفان مبنى قوات
الدعم السريع الجيش يقعان قرب ببعضهم
البعض اليوم
عنيفه بعد ذلك
تفرقت القوات بعد ثم مره اخرى حدث
الاشتباكات وسط المواطنين في السوق وما
الى ذلك لكن
الامر الجيد ان الادارات الاهليه وعدد من
الوسط الى اتفاق بين بين الاطراف وتوقف
القتال وضم اي كل منهما في مكانه وتولد
الشرطه
ومجالات اخرى حمايه الاسواق وحمايه وحصر
الجسار هناك عدد كبير من الجرحى ومن
القتلى ومن الحريق
والاكلاف للسوق وكذلك المعسكرات المحيطه
بالفاجر الفاجر بها معسكرات كثيره جدا
تضررت
جراء هذا هذه الاشتباكات هناك ايضا
حدثت يعني
ابيض ومروي
نعم نروي ليس بها شيء نضيق بها اشتباك بين
القوات الدعم السريع وبين الجيش لكن توقف
هذا الامر هناك جديد ايضا في نياله فيني
اتفق اتفقت الاطراف على تقاسم المدينه
الجانب الشرقي يعني تسيطر عليه الدعم
السريع والجانب الغربي من المدينه بسوق
عليه
ارض المدينه بشكل كبير طيب شكرا لك تفضل
البقاء معي نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي من محيط
مبنى القياده في العاصمه الخرطوم
اذا كما ذكرنا تهدا وتشتد المعارك واطلاق
النار والقذائف حول مقر القياده العامه
على كل حال ينضم الينا من القاهره محمد
ابو الفضل مدير تحرير في جريده الاهرام
والمختص في الشان الافريقي اهلا بك سيد
ابو الفضل وكل عام وانتم بالف خير
بدايه الدلالات تصاعد الحديث عن اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه من قبل الدول الغربيه
وحديث واشنطن على ان يعني الان البيت
الابيض يؤكد بان الطرفين نزاع في السودان
غير ملتزمين بوقف اطلاق النار واكد بانه
يدرس الان
امكانيه اجلاء الرعايه الامريكيين بعد
اعلان مقتل احد الامريكيين برايك هل
يستشعر الغرب ان هذه الحرب ستطول
بالطبع يعني واضح ان تاكدوا رغم ان كل
المؤشرات كانت منذ اليوم الاول تقول ان
هذه الحرب يمكن ان تطول الى اكثر من ايام
يعني لكن التعامل معها كان يبدو في
البدايه في قدر من التمهل والحذر بدليل ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبعض الدول
الغربيه تمهلت في الاعلان عن سحب رعاياها
اما وان الامور بدات تتجه نحو المزيد من
الخبر الخطر ويمكن ان تتدحرج الى
يعني اصابه الكثير من البعثات الاجنبيه
بادرار بالغه لان هذه الحرب المجنونه من
الصعوبه السيطره عليها فكل طرف كما تعرض
لقطاتكم
باقتدار على ان كل طرف يحاول الايحاء بانه
يسيطر على المنطقه ثم يرد عليه الطرف
الاخر الان نحن اذا مشهد عبسي مشهد تتداخل
فيه الكثير من الامور وكل
الرئيس يعني هو المتضرر الاول
في هذه الاخبار العاجله نريد التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار في السودان حتى نتمكن من
اجلاء رعايهنا اذا استمرار الاشتباكات هو
ما يمنع الولايات المتحده من اجلاء
الرعايه من الخرطوم وربما موضوع جزئيه
المطارات وامن المطارات وبالتالي يبدو ان
هناك
نيه حقيقيه لدى الولايات المتحده وبعثات
دبلوماسيه اخرى للخروج من السودان
بالطبع يعني هناك اكثر من دوله تحدثت عن
ذلك والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
توقعات تقول ان هناك قوات امريكيه ترابط
في البحر الاحمر استعدادا للقيام بعمليه
اجلاء معنى ذلك ان مساله المطارات قد تكون
خرجت عن اطار الخدمه لانها تعرضت لتدبير
كبير خلال الايام الماضيه وهذه معضله
كبيره جدا انه سيتم اللجوء الى المواصلات
او الى الطرق البريه وهذه الطرق تكاد تكون
متقطعه ما بين الشرط والغرب والشمال
والجنوب بالنسبه للخرطوم وهي يعني لن يتم
استخدامها او توظيفها فيما يتعلق باجلاج
اجلاء الرعايه ما لم تكن هناك فتره هدنه
او فتره لوقف اطلاق النار فتره معينه
محدده لا احد يخرقها لكن العجيب ان ان
الخطاب الامريكي في هذه المساله هو مرتبط
باخراج الرعايه وليس مرتبط بوقف اطلاق
النار صارم لوقف الحرب اساسا يبدو انهم
يستشعرون ان مساله السيطره عليها قد تكون
صعبه وكذا ذكرت في الساعه السابقه ان
المساله
يمكن ان تكون هي نوع من انواع محاولات
الاستنزاف الطرفين حتى يتم فرد يعني حل
معين من الخارج عليهما لانه من الصعوبه في
ظل اي توازن للقوى ما بين الطرفين سيكون
هناك المعادله ستكون معقده نحن نعود الى
نقطه البدايه وهي اننا امام
الجنرال يتصارعان وهكذا المساله لن تنتهي
بسهوله ما لم تكن هناك الغلبه لطرف او
الانهاك التام لان الامور وصلت الى حائط
مسدود بعد ان سالت الدماء من الطرفين
وبالتالي الاحتكام الى لغه العقل والجلوس
من جديد على طاوله المفاوضات
اصبح امرا بعيد للمنال
للاسف مؤشرات كثيره تقول بذلك لان يعني
اتفاقات الهدى سواء كانت لمده يوم او لمده
72 ساعه لا تصمت اطلاقا بل كمان المثير
للانتباه في المساله ان المجتمع الدولي
حتى الان لم يفرض لم يفرض امرا واقعا فيما
يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار لم يتحدث حول
اجراء حول يعني اتخاذ عقوبات محدده حول من
يخلق وقف اطلاق النار يعني اذا وجدنا
اليوم ان حماتي اعلن انه على السداد
للقبول بوقف النار لمده 72 ساعه فان
البرهان في خطابه الاول اليوم ايضا قال
انه يعني لم يشد باي حال من الاحوال الى
مساله وقف اطلاق النار معنى ذلك انه على
يقين بانه يستطيع حسم الامر عسكريا لصالحك
وهذه المساله غير مضمونه لان الحرب دخلت
في مرحله من الكر والفر بشكل يصعب تحديد
الغلبه ستكون لمن نعم سلاح الطيران دخل في
المعركه لكن هذه ايضا بقدر ما تكون نوع من
انواع التفوق النوع للجيش السوداني لكن
يمكن ان تورطه في كثير من المشاكل لانه
تجمعات قوات الدعم السريع كانت تكون
موجوده في شوارع وبين او في صفوف قوه
مدنيه مختلفه وبالتالي معنى ذلك ان وقوع
المزيد
لانتشار داخل الاحياء المدنيه اود ان
اتحدث معك عن الخطاب البرهان اليوم رغم كل
الثقه التي ابداها البرهان اليوم قائد
الجيش في خطابه ولكن بدا عليه لا ادري اذا
كنت تابعت ولاحظت هذه الملاحظه بدا عليه
التعب والارهاق الموضوع ليس سهلا هذه حرب
بين جيشين كبيرين عاملات جنبا الى جنب
خلال 20 عاما هو يدرك تماما ما تمتلكه
قوات الدعم السريع من خبرات وقدرات وربما
قدره على الصمود وبالتالي تق ديراتك
للامور هل تعتقد بان هناك قناع لدى الجيش
بان هذه الحرب ستطول ستطول ام انه يمكن ان
يحسمها بسرعه
هو لديه اقتناع يعني من خلال هذا الخطاب
لديه اقتناء ان مساله الحاسم اوشكت من
خلال على الاقل المشاهد التي تبثها يبثها
الجسم من خلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
المختلفه تقول ان هناك سيطره ميدانيه على
كثير من المطارات ولا كثير من المواقع لكن
المعضله الرئيسيه في ان هذه المساله يمكن
ان تكون جيده في حاله الحروب النظاميه في
حاله الدوله تحارب دوله لكن دوله تحارب
قوات متغلله في الشوارع وفي المدن
السودانيه هذه المساله في غايه الصعوبه
لكن انا ما لفت نظري في بالنسبه لسؤالك في
خطاب الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان هي نقطه
في غايه الاهميه كانت غائبه ربما سابقا
وهي الاشاره الى تسليم السلطه الى القوه
المدنيه وهذه علامه مهمه جدا يستخدمها
ويوظفها قوات الدعم السريع ويوظفها حميد
في خطابه منذ اليوم الاول لاندلاع الحرب
وكانه يريد ان يقول ان هذه الحرب لصالح
القوى المدنيه لصالح التحول الديمقراطي
وهي ايضا تحمل مغازله غير مباشره للقوه
المجتبعه الدولي التي قد تكون متضرره او
منهكه او غير محبزه لاستمرار الجنس السلطه
هي محاولات لانسان اشارات ايجابيه من
الداخل والخارج اليوم يكاد يكون الفريق
اول عبد الفتاح البرهان حسن هذه المساله
ويريد ان يجاري الخطاب
الديمقراطي او السياسي بين اذا الذي اطلاق
النار في قلب العاصمه الخرطوم انا اعتذر
منك على المقاطعه
اعذرني تماما عن المقاطعه بالتاكيد
سنستفيد من معلومات
حضرتك معنا خلال ساعات التغطيه القادمه
هذه التغطيه مستمره على قناه
العربيه لكن قبل ذلك موجز لاهم الاخبار
[موسيقى]
اعترفت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بان
القوات الروسيه تقدمت في مدينه باخموت
وقالت ان باخموت لا تزال المكان الاكثر
سخونه حيث تدور معارك شرسه حيث تهاجم
روسيا القوات الاوكرانيه وتحقق تقدما في
بعض الاماكن مشيره الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول صد الهجوم الروسي في
اربعه اتجاهات وفي ان واحد
قال للامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
ينسلتنبرغ ان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو في
انضمامها الى حلف الناتو
قلت في كييف بالامس ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
يكمن في الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وكل حلفاء النيتو قد اجمعوا على ان تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو لكن يجب ان نركز
الان على كيفيه ضمان انتصار اوكرانيا في
الحرب ضد روسيا
اكد المتحدث باسم الكرملين
متمثله في ضم اوكرانيا تؤكد صحه قرار
بوتين ببدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه وحذر بسكوب من انميتو يرى موسكو
كخصما للحلف ويعتدي على امن روسيا
هكذا وزير الدفاع الامريكي
تعمل مع الحلفاء والشركاء بشان الوثائق
المسربه في حرب اوكرانيا
اعلم ان الكثير منكم كان يتابع التقارير
قضيه تسريب الوثائق الحساسه الامريكيه
دققت في هذه القضيه بشكل جاد ونعمل عن قرب
مع الحلفاء والشركاء الذين اكدوا لنا
دعمهم الكامل لن تسمح باي محاولات للنيل
من وحدتنا
حضر وزير الخارجيه الصينيه تشينجانج من ان
انتقاد الصين بشان تايوان سيكون له عواقب
وخيمه ان هناك خطابات تتحدث عن تغيير
الوضع الراهن من جانب واحد عبر مضيق
تايوان من خلال القوه او الاكراه وتعطيل
السلام والاستقرار عبر المضيق مشيرا الى
ان مثل هذه الادعاءات تتعارض مع طبيعه
العلاقات الدوليه ولها عواقب خطيره
انتقدت بكين عزمة واشنطن فرد قيود جديده
على استثمارات الشركات الامريكيه في بكين
معتبره ان خطوه هذه هي اقرب الى ان تكون
اكراه اقتصادي فاضح وتنمر تكنولوجي وتدرس
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن برنامجا لتقييد
استثمارات خارجيه امريكيه بما يشمل بعض
التقنيات الحساسه التي قد تكون لها اثار
على الامن القومي
الى المانيا حيث بدا عمال السكك الحديديه
اضرابا في جميع انحاء البلاد ما ادى لتوقف
الخدمه في السكك الحديديه وفي اربع مطارات
المانيه هذا وتشهد المانيا منذ العام
الماضي بعضا من اوسع الاضرابات التي ادت
او اذا ادت الحرب في اوكرانيا الى ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه والغذاء ما دفع العمال للضغط
من اجل زياده الاجور بما يتماشى مع تكاليف
المعيشه
وزيرا للعدل في بريطانيا خلفا لدومين كراب
المستقيل كما حل اوليفر دوروم بدلا عن ربط
في منصب نائب رئيس الحكومه وكان نائب رئيس
الوزراء البريطانيه ووزير العدل الدوميني
كراب استقاله من منصبه في وقت سابق بعد
تحقيق مستقل في شكاوى رسميه بشان تصرفاته
وذلك اثر وابر من الاتهامات حول سلوكه
وتنمره تجاه العديد من الموظفين الحاليين
والسابقين خلال فتره عمله في الحكومه
الموجز الان نعود لاستكمال تغطيه لابرز
احداث السودان لكن مع الزميله رشا نبيل
على راس الساعه ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه
في اشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات